mas a todas é um grande prazer estar
aqui hoje a vontade é essa versão
internet que tem como lema ideias que
merecem ser compartilhadas e eu gostaria
de conversar um pouco com vocês sobre a
questão da inclusão da pessoa com
deficiência no mercado de trabalho que
foram temporalmente situação de mestrado
que depois se transformou no livro
quando nós falamos de inclusão da pessoa
com deficiência no mercado de trabalho
eu estou aqui e lecionando para vocês
dois direitos fundamentais sociais
o direito ao trabalho ea assistência aos
desamparados porque a pessoa com
deficiência se enquadra nessa categoria
a assistência aos desamparados
os direitos fundamentais eles são um
núcleo de direito sim tangíveis que não
podem ser colhidos nós chamamos de multa
em torno da constituição dentro dos
direitos fundamentais sociais nós temos
os direitos fundamentais sociais que são
aqueles que têm por objetivo erradicar a
desigualdade sociais
então nós estamos falando de saúde de
educação de nahla grêmio de assistência
dos funcionários
então quando nós estamos aqui
conversando também é muito importante a
gente ter uma noção de que segundo o
censo 2010 é alarmante o processo de
exclusão que se confessou
o mercado de 53 por cento das pessoas
com deficiência em idade ativa do nosso
país estão falar no mercado de trabalho
elas não se encontram ocupadas e esse é
o processo de exclusão que vem aí se
arrastando há 12 anos no censo de 2000
também não havia dados favoráveis nesse
sentido visando erradicar essa
desigualdade no brasil ele promoveu
então a ação afirmativa mais emblemática
que nós temos nesse sentido que é o que
nós chamamos de lei de cotas para
pessoas com deficiência a chamada lei de
cotas na verdade é o artigo 93 da lei
8.213 91 que determina que todas as
pessoas jurídicas empresas com mais de
100 funcionários têm a obrigação de
contratar uma determinada porcentagem de
empregados com deficiência
essa é a problemática bom eu posso dizer
pra vocês que este artigo de lei ele tem
se produzido com os resultados nós temos
resultados interessantes é o suficiente
não é bom o começo falei pra vocês por
cento em 2010 disse que 53 por cento da
população com deficiência não está
obrigada
então o que falta pra essa
se tornar mais efetiva a essa legislação
ela não é perfeita e nós temos que
trabalhar em cima dela visando buscar as
soluções e também identificando os
problemas
quais são os problemas nessa legislação
bom eu construí algo para vocês que eu
identifiquei na minha pesquisa primeira
vez
muitas empresas argumentam que ela já
possui o seu quadro de funcionários
absolutamente completo e que não podem
arcar com o custo da contratação de mais
empregados
ainda vamos ter de ir empregados para
contratar outros que têm deficiência não
a gente também não pode criar um
problema para resolver outro então qual
é a solução
as empresas não podem contratar mais
porque já tem um quadro de funcionários
completos e também não tem condição de
arcar com esse ônus
ó a solução que eu proponho é uma
solução que já é feita na holanda ao
andré que tem uma legislação de cotas
ela não apenas determina a contratação
mas ela também prevê incentivos fiscais
para as empresas que contratam
empregados com deficiência
dessa forma a empresa pode então
compensar com esse ônus na contratação
de mais funcionários
é uma boa alternativa os incentivos
fiscais
o segundo problema também identificado é
a questão da qualificação
funcional as empresas também argumentam
isso já foi levado ao poder judiciário
que muitas vezes não conseguem cumprir a
legislação de cotas porque elas não
encontram empregados é que tenho a
qualificação para um determinado cargo
o meu judicial analisando essas questões
que flexibilizou em mais atenção e
sensibilizar não significa descumprir a
lei
só podemos chegar à conclusão de que as
empresas não conseguiu encontrar
empregados qualificados então não
precisa cumprir a lei não não é se a
solução que vem sendo encontrada é o
acordo entre os órgãos fiscalizadores do
malaio e essas empresas no sentido de
que vocês vão ter um tempo para
preencher a cota o em e vocês vão ter
que usar esse tempo de um ou dois anos
dependendo do caso para investir em
programas de qualificação profissional e
qualificando essas pessoas vocês poderão
posteriormente empregados é uma solução
muito criativa que tem sido também
utilizar o telecentro novela e que pra
mim é o mais grave de todos é a situação
da empresa eo ministério público tem
recebido muitas denúncias nesse sentido
tailandesa que pré à pessoa com
deficiência registra pagar um salário
mas não lhe dá uma função
a pessoa fica em casa recebe salário
formalmente já está empregada quais ela
não tem trabalho será que isso resolve o
problema da inclusão não porque nós
temos que ter em mente que o trabalho
não tenha
no sentido de prover o sustento de uma
pessoa
é claro que todos nós trabalhamos pra
qualquer nossa subsistência mas o
trabalho é muito mais importante que
isso é a abrangência do trabalho a
importância do trabalho da nossa vida um
capaz a questão o sustento
nós estamos falando aqui de uma
atividade que nos proporciona a
possibilidade de desenvolvermos as suas
habilidades dos nossos potenciais novos
talentos é talvez na barra que nós temos
um papel na comunidade em que nós
vivemos
então o trabalho é importante na vida de
uma pessoa e uma empresa não pode
cumprir a legislação de cotas somente no
seu sentido numérico informal
nós temos que ter em mente a função
social da lei que é promover um trabalho
no sentido mais completo que isso
significa na vida da pessoa com
deficiência
gostaria também de deixar para vocês uma
mensagem de que promoverá a inclusão da
pessoa com deficiência no mercado de
trabalho não é uma medida que deve ser
tida como tema a lógica piedosa ou
caridosa fica cada vez mais forte na
percepção das empresas do setor
empresarial de forma geral que promover
a diversidade dos seus estabelecimentos
o pluralismo no seu quadro de
funcionários só traz benefícios à
empresa que benefícios
uma empresa que promove a inclusão ela
tem uma imagem associada à
responsabilidade social
e isso com certeza vai se refletir no
seu relacionamento com seus clientes e
fornecedores
uma empresa que promove a divina
seus estabelecimentos ela contém promove
um ambiente de trabalho humanizado e 30
de um ambiente de trabalho humanizado
todos eu repito todos os trabalhadores
com ou sem deficiência ter uma
possibilidade muito maior de desenvolver
as suas potencialidades
então a idéia é que haja de forma
socialmente responsável
ela acolhe muitos benefícios com essa eu
queria também deixar a mensagem de que o
trabalho é a força que pode promover uma
sociedade e quando há nenhuma sociedade
inclusiva é o trabalho que tem o poder
de produzir gerar e distribuir riquezas
de maneira justa
esse foi o trabalho de todas as pessoas
eu posso garantir que nós estamos no
caminho tá inclusão da sociedade de
música e para que nós possamos promover
a inclusão do trabalho da pessoa com
deficiência a gente tem que considerar a
diferença é considerando a diferença que
se promove a igualdade ea dignidade que
são os esteios do nosso ordenamento
jurídico
me descobri